[Musique]
et notre habileté politique ce matin
c'est valérie un bon jour à l'erea
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
depuis tes de tarn et garonne jean
président du groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée nationale
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale qui est
dans sa rédaction bonjour jai personnes
des sports merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui les locaux de sud ouest
votre journal bonjour jefferson
on commence par ce budget valérie
rabault bien sûr vous êtes l'une des
parlementaires spécialistes du budget le
gouvernement qui a donc présenté ce
budget 2021 avec des chiffres on va le
dire qu'ils donnent le vertige 152
milliards de déficit
6 7% l'an prochain une dette à 116 % du
pib
est-ce que ce budget vous le qualifiez
de budget hors normes oui mais oui leurs
normes depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
jamais on a connu une telle crise qui
affecte les économies nos pays donc oui
il est hors norme
la question qui se pose est celle de son
ciblage celle de sa mise en oeuvre et
celles de son calibrage
quand vous avez et c'est là dessus que
nous avons des divergences avec le
gouvernement je rappelle que mon groupe
et c'est la même chose ici
pour les sénateurs socialistes et
apparentés ont voté les deux premiers
budget de relance le plfr un lep fr2 et
là nous disons parce qu'il y avait
urgence
il fallait fait à créer le fonds de
solidarité lancée les garanties d'état
donc tout ça il n'y avait pas de
discussion là dessus en revanche là
aujourd'hui nous estimant qu'il ya une
un défaut de ciblage un défaut de mise
en oeuvre et un défaut de calibrage donc
c'est à dire vous dites stop celui-là
vous ne le vendrai pas telle qu'elle ne
votera pas telle qu'elle s'est il ya des
plans d'investissement mais y'a pas un
vrai plan de relance comme ce qu'ont
fait les allemands je rappelle que les
allemands ont sorti leur plan de relance
le 3 juin et le gouvernement a annoncé
son plan de relance le 3 septembre pour
une mise en oeuvre dans ce budget
c'est à dire pas avant le 1er janvier
2021 le gouvernement nous parle de 100
milliards c'est le chiffre totem bon
alors quand on prend sa petite
calculatrice ou son fichier excel et
qu'on recompte qui a en 2021
on est au mieux je dis bien au mieux à
35 milliards d'euros c'est à dire un
tiers c'est par rapport aux 130
milliards que l'allemagne dégage dès
2021 voyez quand on est très très loin
donc mais le gouvernement de ne dit pas
le contraire il admet qu'il ya 10
milliards seulement de baisses d'impôts
de production cette année qui avait il
dit van den acker de lady gaga est en
responsabilité sur la relance il ya des
moments dans la vie où quand on fait les
choses trop tard et bien c'est trop tard
si vous ne soutenez pas y'a rien pour
les tpe les pme et le ministre l'a
reconnu à demi mot lundi dernier quand
il nous a présenté ce budget en disant
effectivement il ya des trous importants
les tpe et les pme sont le poumon
économique moi je ne pose jamais les
grandes entreprises aux tpe pme
mais je dis que si on les laisse tomber
maintenant une fois qu'elles seront
mortes
on pourra pas aller relever donc ça
c'est une vraie priorité qui est
absolument absente de ce budget la
deuxième ce matin est sorti le baromètre
2020 du secours populaire réalisé avec
ipsos
quand vous entendez que 57% des français
ont peur de tomber dans la pauvreté
depuis le départ nous disons il faut un
plan de soutien vraiment au pouvoir
d'achat pour les personnes qui ont vu
leur pouvoir d'achat le plus diminué
sont les personnes qui enchaîne des
petits jobs qui n'ont plus ce sont les
étudiants qui étaient souvent qui
serveur dans un restaurant comme
éraillée beaucoup de restaurants ferment
tout à fait ou plutôt ils n'ont plus
petits boulots enfin vous voyez toutes
ces questions là quand vous faites des
plus pour certaines familles pour
certains ménages c'est extrêmement
pénalisant et dans ce budget y a pas de
réponse on va rentrer dans les détails
de ce budget avec jefferson dans
quelques secondes mais ce matin vous
nous dites
armand tel que présenté par bruno le
maire les députés socialistes ne
voteront pas oui enfin non ils ne
voteront pas non gestion
voilà jefferson valérie rabault à la
lueur de la crise sanitaire sur toutes
ces incertitudes
est-ce que je chez elle pense déjà
fragile sinon caduque
mais je considère illescas d'une en ce
sens où il ya des partis qui n'existe
pas notamment celle sur les tpe pme
notamment celles en direction des
ménages qui ont vu l'une chute de
revenus importants je pense aux
intérimaires
je pense aux étudiants en tant qu encore
une fois la jeunesse est très pénalisés
par cette crise parce qu'on leur dit on
va aider les entrepreneurs qui vont vous
embaucher mais si vous n'êtes pas
embaucher vous n'êtes pas aidé du tout
vous n'avez pas le droit au rsa parce
que vous avez moins de 25 ans vous
n'avez plus les petits jobs que vous
pouviez assuré à côté de vos études
parce que des restaurants ferment donc
quand vous sommet tout ça la seule
mesure positive celle et un euro au
crous pour les étudiants boursiers mais
ça concerne une toute petite minorité
et encore faut-il qu'ils puissent
revenir à l'université parce que
certaines ont fermé pour des raisons
sanitaires
non alors là je ne ferai pas je ferais
pas un procès en instance réalité parce
que bien malin qui pourrait dire ce que
sera la croissance en 2021 évidemment
quand on construit un budget il faut
faire des hypothèses ça permet de
calibrer mais je ne ferai pas de budget
je ne ferai pas de procès en sincérité
parce que honnêtement je ne suis pas
madame soleil je sais pas ce qui se
passera l'an prochain mais vous dites
que compte tenu des éléments dont on
dispose de gouvernement à l'heure
actuelle ce budget est sincère alors on
se bat oui enfin il n'est pas un sincère
en tout cas il ya une prévision de
croissance qui est sur la table 2 8%
pour 2021 est ce que ça vous y croyez ou
est ce que c'est encore une fois un
certain alors de toute façon personne
n'en sait rien mais ce qui est sûr c'est
que je ne croyais pas à la chute du pib
en 2020 aussi importante et je peux vous
dire quand le président de la république
a reçu les présidents de groupes début
juillet je le lui dis donc c'est pas
quelque chose que j'aurais écrit trois
mois après pour écrire l'histoire
maintenant est ce que ce sera u % est ce
que le gouvernement a cherché à
peut-être un peu accentué la crise pour
pouvoir accentuer leur bon je n'en sais
rien et honnêtement c'est pas le débat
pour les français qui ont perdu leurs
emplois qui sont en chômage partiel et
qui n'a pas pour lequel le complément de
salaire n'a pas pu être assurée par
l'entreprise je pense que c'est pas le
débat chômage partiel juste des
personnes avant de parler du chômage
partiel sur ce budget qui contient les
mesures du plan de relance 1 vous le
disiez il contient ces 100 milliards qui
ne sont pas 100 milliards dans le budget
mais est ce que c'est une erreur de
mettre les mesures de plans de relance
dans le budget est ce que finalement
c'est un peu confondent l'urgence est le
plus long terme
est ce qu'il aurait fallu de deux textes
distincts moi je alors je suis pas leur
place mais je pense que la lisibilité
budgétaire ça permet de la lisibilité
politique donc ce qui est d'un plan
d'urgence j'aurais ils ont créé une
mission plan d'urgence sauf qu'il ya
tout dedans y compris des plans
d'investissement je dis pas qu'ils sont
pas bien ses plans d'investissements dis
juste qu'ils ne peuvent pas être
confondue avec de la relance parce que
si vous commencez à lancer un projet à
la fin de l'année prochaine il aura des
effets en 2022 ou 2023
donc il faut dire voilà il ya un plan
pour le futur vous l'appelez plan
d'investissement et puis un plan de
relance est tout de suite c'est vraiment
tout de suite
ja il n'y a pas le temps donc il ne
valait pas le mettre dans le budget
c'est me voulaient pas les mettre dans
le budget pour vous et faire trois
parties dans le budget la partie
récurrente la partie plan de relance la
partie plan d'investissement et là je
pense que vous avez une visibilité plus
importante que ce qui existe aujourd'hui
et puis dans le budget il faut dire les
choses telles qu'elles sont vous n'avez
pas 100 milliards dans le budget c'est
faux vous en avez 35 et j'ai posé la
question au ministre en me disant je
viens de faire une petite addition il
m'a pas démenti il était peut-être à 34
bon voilà donc il ya un tiers du plan de
relance qui est dans le budget 2021 mais
pas plus jefferson sur le chômage
partiel
we all go à mouches sur cette mesure la
quine les mesures fortes les mesures de
réponse à cette crise est ce que vous
direz que l'on a bien protégé que les
salariés et l'on avait généralisé c'est
pour le coup ça a été une bonne réponse
la question qui se pose aujourd'hui
c'est comment on a aussi demandé s'il y
avait différents scénarios si la crise
perdure si on trouve le vaccin
tardivement fin enfin là on peut en
faire deux ou trois de dire comment on
accompagne aussi la sortie du chômage
partiel
comment on accompagne la sortie du plan
du de la garantie d'état le fameux pge
parce que certaines entreprises vont
normalement appelées à rembourser donc
comment on les accompagne sur cette
question là et enfin comment ma compagne
le paiement d un certain nombre
d'entreprises nous nous avions demandé
de l'annulation de cotisation le
gouvernement et finalement il a accédé
pour tous les établissements qui ont été
fermées entre le mois de mars pendant le
confinement
je pense qu'il faut y aller regarder les
choses plus finement et peut-être
étendre ces reports de cotisations en
annulation de cotisation tout cas ce que
nous demandions pour permettre à des
entreprises de continuer à vivre parce
que pour certaines ça va signifier la
fin en tout cas la mort de l'entreprise
est de toute façon l'état y sera perdre
en puisque les cotisations ne seront in
fine et pas payer donc je les tente
jusqu'à quand jusqu'à la fin de l'année
par il va regarder jusqu'à la fin
d'année oui en tout cas sur cette
question l'urgence aujourd'hui c'est la
fermeture des restaurants et des bars
donc c'est dans les villes les plus
impactés est ce que nous le maire à
milliards de mesures suffisantes
c'est 3 milliards ça représente déjà une
enveloppe significative
il faut vraiment le reconnaître encore
une fois ce qui est perturbant dans les
annonces du gouvernement c'est sur ce
point là en tout cas c'est le fait qu'il
n'y a pas de ligne claire vis-à-vis de
la stratégie du gouvernement concernant
la politique sanitaire nous quand on a
vu je vais vous dire la semaine dernière
le premier ministre a reçu les
présidents de groupe et les chefs de
parti et donc je lui ai dit mais sur le
site de la rs sur le site du
gouvernement sur le site de ces la ceppm
site internet sont pas les mêmes choses
qui sont écrites
comment voulez vous que les français s'y
retrouve c'est incompréhensible donc il
faut une mode d'emploi qu'ils soient
précis et qui soit le même partout
qu'est ce qui vous a répondu le premier
la balle quand il a vu les trois
exemples avec 3 communication différente
du gouvernement ça faisait un peu vilain
quand même
qui ont été un peu embêté je vais pas
engagé à plus de clarté plus mais je
pense que si il a dit fera le corriger
bon voilà donc c'est ça c'est une
réalité
et après il dit je veux faire de la
concertation avec les territoires donc
c'était son oui mais si c'est pas comme
ça c'est parce qu'on fait de la
concertation avec les territoires sauf
que le lendemain on découvre qu'il n'a
parlé ni à paris ni à marseille pour
déterminer ce qu'il fallait engager
donc ça ça va pas du tout il faut qu ils
les engagent des discussions avec les
collectivités avec les villes et après
il assume les décisions qui et c'est lui
le chef du gouvernement c'est lui qui
doit a su mais ces mesures notamment à
aix marseille qui ont été annoncées le
lendemain de votre réunion il ne vous en
avez absolument pas à lire les notes de
votre réunion pas dit un mot donc michel
delahaye a pas être concertation s'est
vue de 18h à 20h 45 et ben en 2h45 là on
n'a pas dit un mot
et alors le lendemain il fait ses
annonces et le surlendemain l'aider les
arrêter sorte et son recorrigé le soir
notamment pour paris le préfet de police
de paris à rémy un nouvel arrêté c'est
quand même je crois que là là dessus
c'est peu beaucoup beaucoup mieux faire
iriez jusqu'à parlé d'amateurisme à ce
sujet là ça va pas il faut qu'ils aient
une cohérence c'est anxiogène quand le
matin on vous dit il faut faire ci et le
soir on vous dit le contraire je prends
l'exemple des piscines à paris bon voilà
c'est un exemple mais tout est comme ça
il faut aussi que sur les thèses depuis
départ mais on a expliqué que ça pouvait
pas être open bar parce que ça prive les
personnes qui en ont le plus besoin
qu'ils doivent attendre sept jours ça me
ça veut dire quoi que vous êtes sept
jours chez vous en attente du test vous
savez pas si alors maintenant vous êtes
le sens et le savoir si mais au début
vous saviez pas si vous avez un arrêt
maladie ou pas fan tout ceci il faut de
l'organisation
l'organisation c'est pas une privation
liberté c'est juste de dire on donne une
direction on fixe un cap et c'est pas
anxiogène comme c'est aujourd'hui il ya
suffisamment de raisons pour que ce soit
monsieur james en a rajouté des
personnes sur le secteur de
l'aéronautique ans et que c'est une
question qui inquiète beaucoup dans le
sud reste bien sûr mais valérie rabault
jetons sur ce secteur aéronautique dans
cette crise
maintenant on a un père état providence
l 160 milliards d'euros sur la table
toutes les cultures
est ce que c'est une bonne définition
dans ce cas pas 460 milliards d'euros
c'est je suis fier comme je peux vous
sommet des choux et des carottes et puis
je serai contente ça n'a rien à voir il
ya 300 milliards de garanties et
ministre a dit que sur les 300 milliards
de garantie il a dit lundi dernier il
n'avait 120 milliards qui ont été
accordés donc vous voyez moi aussi je
peux communiquer sur 460 vannes
c'est n'importe quoi de dire 460 passe
consomment des choux et des 40 c n'a
rien à voir donc il ya de la garantie et
il ya des aides sur les aides quand on
avoue quand la majorité a voté le plan
de relance 3 fin le plfr 3 il y avait 20
milliards pour le chômage partiel 20
milliards pour les entreprises et 20
milliards pour l'hôpital et star est un
bon sur les entreprises à votre ami y en
a combien qui a été décaissée a
aujourd'hui 000 documents sur les
entreprises sur les 20 milliards ou 0
bon donc ça c'est un petit sujet quand
même parce que la recette pour un plan
de relance c'est la vitesse il faut les
mettre en oeuvre tout de suite
donc moi je rencontre les acteurs aérien
je rencontre vendredi prochain le pdg
d'air france donc toutes ces questions
là parce que vous avez raison
l'aéronautique est un secteur très
sinistré ça fait partie des points que
avec moi j'ai fait aussi l'inquiétude
sur l'emploi dans votre région mais bien
sûr je le fais aussi au titre de mes
fonctions rapporteur spécial pour les
participations de l'état qui
effectivement là on est au coeur du
sujet il faut que le ski a été votée
puisse être décaissés c'est à dire que
je suis impressionné une vraie réalité
est ce que vous êtes flux qui leur est
d'apporter un france notamment sont
suffisantes pour qu'un compagnon travers
cette crise mais il faut déjà encore
faut-il qu'elle soit versée
il ya des questions qui se posent un
puisqu'on parle de ces aides aux
entreprises à des questions qu'ils se
posent sur les contreparties
oui est-ce que lors de l'examen de ce
budget vous allez déposer des
amendements vous socialiste pour qui est
déjà parent nous on fera un contre
budget vous l'appelez on en a fait un
chacun comme chaque année donc voilà
et on fera un plan contrepartie
c'est-à-dire de dire par type de dead
qu'est ce qui doit être associé en
termes de contrepartie un plan contre
partie qui sera dans d'autres contrées
budget et qui n'a évidemment rien forme
d'amendements lors de l'examen du budget
exactement
vous pouvez nous en dire un tout petit
peu plus sur ce qui aura précisé mais je
vais pas tout vous dévoiler tout de
suite mais parce que on le travaille on
essaie de faire un travail collectif
mais il est sûr que il doit y avoir des
contreparties en terme d'agenda
environnementale elle s est pas un gros
mot ne demandaient des contreparties
quand on est élus parlementaires
sénateurs ou députés
on est comptable de l'argent public on
est responsable parce que l'argent
public c'est pas de l'argent magique
c'est toujours les impôts des français
une finale car ces contreparties n'y
sont pas valérie rabault avait dans le
budget d'aujourd'hui non justement
soirée sur les impôts jefferson
puisqu'on parle d un voilier français
c'est une des annonces reçues un budget
2021 gouvernement prévoit une baisse de
10 milliards les impôts de production
est ce que c'est
j'y croyais est ce que c'est une mesure
pour préserver l'emploi je pense que
c'est une mesure qui n'est pas très bien
ciblé dans le sens où parce que là au
point où on en est il faut faire du
chirurgicale encore une fois je reviens
sur le fait qu' il ya vous avez les
grandes entreprises qui ont besoin
d'être des locomotives sur des filières
on pense notamment puisque vous parlez
de la région occitanie on pense à airbus
bien entendu donc ils doivent être aidés
spécifiquement et puis après il ya
toutes les parties des tpe pme qui pour
le coup n'ont pas de soutien à ce stade
donc c'est bien ce volet là qui doit
entrer en oeuvre dans une mesure de
relance que fait le gouvernement en
disant je baisse les impôts de
production il avait envie de le faire
depuis le départ depuis qu'il est arrivé
en responsabilité en juin 2017 il avait
envie de le faire il saisit l'occasion
de nous habiller sa dans un plan de
relance mais ça ne c'est pas ça qui va
générer de la relance c'est pourtant là
dans un bilan d'une entreprise qui
génère de la relance et la première
ligne ça s'appelle le chiffre d'affaires
dernière question sur le budget avant de
passer un hôtel jefferson est ce que je
peux en tout cas on sait que le premier
ministre ne veut pas financer ce plan de
relance en renard entendu vos critiques
dessus alors notre montant les impôts s
le premier ministre ne veut pas le
premier ministre ne dit pas comment ils
financent le plan de relance il dit bon
on fera la dette puis on verra plus tard
depuis avril donc ça maintenant ça va
faire six mois on demande une conférence
de financement de la crise c'est quand
même pas un gros mot on peut se mettre
tous autour de la table responsables
politiques responsables syndicaux
patronaux pour dire voilà comment on
peut financer la crise
alors ça peut être de différentes façons
il ya évidemment la dette mais dont on
doit quand même avoir une petite idée de
la manière dont on va la gérer
et puis nous nous disons comme dans
chaque crise il doit y avoir une
contribution est d'ailleurs un certain
nombre de clubs de millionnaires l'on
demande et qu'ils puissent y aura une
contribution des plus aisés donc ça ne
vous surprendra pas mais moi ce que je
reproche au premier ministre
au delà des différentes options
politiques que nous avons c'est de faire
croire que l'argent serait magique
ce que je veux c'est qu'il y ait une
conférence de financement qu'on se
mettre autour de la table pour demander
le retour d'oliech
enfin je le demande pas je leur heureux
demande c'est chaque année où l'on re re
re demande et crise ou pas crise allez
quelques questions aux politiques pour
finir valérie rabault et les
sénatoriales qui ont eu lieu dimanche et
le groupe socialiste au sénat qui perd
quand même quelques sièges à ce que la
gauche paye ses divisions
bah oui parce que si on regarde dans
beaucoup de départements notamment où
des sièges n'ont pas été gagnée ou
certains ont été perdus voyez que le
nombre de voix ci avait pas eu des
listes à multiplication faisait que la
gauche pouvait largement récupéré les
sièges et quatre ou cinq qui ont été
perdus et surtout en gagner le mode de
scrutin
quand on fait un tour c'est sega pas une
chance y'a pas de chance il y en a une
seule
donc il faut voilà il faut salir leçons
pour l'avenir pour les prochaines
échéances et toujours une leçon pour
l'avenir la gauche paye de ses divisions
et justement l'avenir on va commencer
par les régionales c'est la prochaine
échéance carole delga qui officialise
ehsayer sa candidature dans votre région
occitanie vous la soutenez on vous
l'avait dit mais c'est une région qui
est menacé par le rassemblement national
a on le voit dans un sondage qui a été
publié récemment où le rassemblement
national talonne carole delga comment
conserver votre région est ce que vous
êtes inquiète
une élection ça saute toujours jusqu'au
bout c'est comme un match de rugby
jusqu'à la dernière minute
mais d'abord je suis très contente que
carole delga et annoncer sa candidature
c'est une présidente qui a la niaque qui
est vraiment un vrai moteur pour notre
région qui travaillent énormément qui a
sillonné quinquin de l'occitanie puisque
la région a été fusionné en 2015 c'est
la fusion de deux régions est vraiment
elle a réussi à créer cette identité à
faire en sorte que voilà on se sentent
maintenant moi je me sens proche du gard
de montpellier qui était quand même ce
qui était moins intuitif au départ
lorsque la région ont été créés dont
elle a vraiment réussi ce pari là c'est
la région de france qui investit le plus
alors publics et privés donc il ya un
vrai moteur effectivement là on a dit
difficulté sur l'aéronautique et que
personne vanier politiquement il ya
effectivement une montée importante du
rassemblement national il ya eu une des
fins et une victoire du rassemblement
national à perpignan mais quand on
regarde aussi le sondage en détail
ça c'est le premier tour avec
effectivement de nombreuses listes qui
sont à gauche notamment notamment à
gauche quand on regarde une fille née
sur la question qui était posée aussi
sur le second tour on voit que voilà
carole delga est vraiment celle qui
incarne un ps un éventuel rassemblement
national il faut l'union de la gauche
dès le premier tour en occitanie faut
réussir l'union la plus large
moi je ne suis pas dans les négociations
c'est ce sera à elle de les mener bien
sûr mais il faut l'union la plus large
parce que il y à un danger et je crois
qu'une victoire la plus nette possible
un score le plus élevé possible serait
un très très bon message autres régions
c'est l'ile-de-france et une tribune qui
a été publié hier notamment par olivier
faur anne hidalgo pour une union au sein
d'ile-de-france en commun est ce que
pour vous la bonne candidate c'est
audrey pulvar en ile de france mais je
sais pas qui sera candidat ou pas parce
que les délais candidatures sont en ce
moment sein des désignations que nous
faisons je connais moi la situation en
ile de france
par contre j'ai trouvé que la tribune
était très bien il ya bernard cazeneuve
aussi qu'ils la signent
beaucoup de personnalités c'est vraiment
l'idée de se dire il faut voilà et un
moment donné il faut taire notre petite
querelle elles continueront mais on le
sait mais ce qui compte c'est quand on a
un objet
civc se concentrer sur l'objectif et pas
sur les petites graines et une dernière
question jefferson questions sur les
petites querelles les divisions de la
gauche la présidentielle 2022 approche
vous le savez valérie rabault est ce que
vous êtes prête à soutenir une
éventuelle candidature d'annecy au maire
de paris
question puisse prolonger soit sceptique
je suis je pense que anne hidalgo ferait
une très bonne candidate et je vais même
vous dire plus je pense qu'elle ferait
une très bonne présidente de la
république donc vous la soutenez pour
elle c'est la grâce de dates de la
gauche je la soutiens vous en avez parlé
avec elle vous savez c'est alors si elle
en a envie c'est à l'approché de les
croiser très rapidement on va se voir
prochainement donc pour l'instant oui je
vous le dit spontanément sans avoir
échangé sur un sujet avec lm confirmé
que la boule retour berne hidalgo non
mais je vous crois là c'est un voile à
chaque année je rencontre la maire de
paris avant le budget chaque année
seulement je vous le dis pas sur le
plateau dont vous ne le savez pas vous
pouvez pas en tirer les conclusions
donc à nouveau je vais la rencontre et
sur le budget comme je voulais chaque
année et je la soutiens
voilà merci beaucoup merci jefferson on
va regarder la une de sud ouest le sport
girondins boit la tasse c'est à la une
de sud ouest aujourd'hui merci d'avoir
été avec nous des personnes merci merci
à vous